electrocardiogram or ECG is a technique
which is used to check the heart's
Rhythm and electrical activity we all
know that heart in a human body is a
pump which pumps by mechanical activity
of the muscles this mechanical activity
of the muscles is derived by the
electrical activity in the AC node and
conductive systems of the heart ECG is
an investigation which tells us about
the electrical activity of heart
sensors are attached to the skin and are
used to detect the electrical signals
produced by your heart each time the
heart beats now why ECG is done now ECG
is done
to diagnose certain conditions like
irregular heart rhythms medically known
as arrhythmias
if block on narrowed arteries are
present that is coronary artery disease
heart blocks these things can be also
identified
whether you are having a heart attack or
undergoing a heart attack or have a
previous history of heart attack that
can be checked by ECG and how will
certain heart disease treatments such as
pacemaker are working
you should also know that there's no
fear in doing an ECG because ECG is a
painless non-invasive way to help
diagnose many common heart problems and
it is quite reasonably priced as well
now how an ECG is carried out now ECG is
carried out by connecting sensors on the
human body and these sensors are
connected to a machine which gives a
reading of electrical activity on a
graphical paper and this electrical
activity shows the electrical
functioning of different parts of the
human heart
now how the electrodes or the sensors of
the ECG are placed now sensors can be
placed in different ways there is a
vertical plane and there is a horizontal
plane now all the sensors in the
vertical planar over here blue now there
are six sensors what are those there is
one two and three which are known as the
classical limb Blitz then we have AVR
AVL and avf which are the augmented limb
lids and finally we have V1 V2 V3 V4 V5
and V6 which are present in a horizontal
axis a horizontal plane and sees hard
from anterior to posterior Direction and
these are known as the chest bleeds so
in total we have 12 leads of ECG but in
certain ECGs in special conditions we
can use more than 12 bleeds as well
but let's not talk about that in this
video
now how to read an ECG Trace now ECG
output is seen on a graphical paper and
on the graphical paper the electrical
activity is stressed as in a graphical
format
now in this graphical format if we see
there is something known as a P wave
which shows arterial atrial
depolarization
then there's something known as the r
wave which shows the ventricular
depolarization together with a Qs and S
Wave this is known as QRS complex after
that we have something known as the T
wave and U wave which indicates the
ventricular repolarization and
papillary muscle repolarization
finally this is how a normal ECG looks
like but in certain disease conditions
as in bradycardia you can see a ECG like
this over here you can see that your
heart beats or number of beating of
heart is less than 60 times per minute
that is unusual slowing of heart rate
similarly there can be something known
as unusual fastening of heart rate that
is more than 100 beats per minute that
is seen in case of tachycardia or there
can be arrhythmia where there's an
irregularity gross irregularity in the
electrical impulse of the heart and the
heart does not work properly
now there's something known as acute
myocardial infarction that is heart
attack in that case you can see ST
segment elevation that is in case of a
ST segment elevated myocardial
infarction this is a very common and
emergent condition that is diagnosed
with using ECG
apart from these normal ECGs we can have
special types of ECGs like a halter
monitoring where the sensors are
connected to the body and finally they
go to a small portable monitor
monitoring device known as the halter
Monitor and it shows ECG reading for
throughout the day so you can get a
throughout the day 24 7 ECG monitor I
mean heart rate or heart electrical
impulses monitoring
then there's something known as a
treadmill test in which a patient is
fitted with the sensors of ECG connected
to a ECG machine and finally the patient
walks on a treadmill this is to create a
stressful situation for the patient and
to see how the heart is functioning
under stressful situations so this is
kind of a stress test also known as a
treadmill test or TMT
I believe this summarizes the basic
concepts of ECG
if you have enjoyed our video please hit
the like button share this video in your
friends and peers of your medical school
and college
to get notes and flash cards you can
follow us on our Facebook page and
Instagram at animated biology with arpan
the link will be in the description box
below also to make high quality
educational content for free we need
your support
to support us you can use a super thanks
icon to support our Channel you can find
that icon on the bottom right corner of
any video and you can pay using paytm
PayPal or UPI also you can follow us on
patreon and contribute in our strive
towards making free high quality content
you can scan the QR code to pay
if you wish to connect with arpan you
can use the social media links given in
the description box below this video was
made in collaboration with the nerd
medic for medicine related content
follow nerd medic YouTube channel and to
get in touch with the Nordic you can
follow these links mentioned over here
until then bye bye see you in the next
one